we're going to put together instead of a
seat down the bottom here is always
helpful when you have a grants to say
what they're talking about
I don't actually know if this is a verb
I'm just going to call them scorn but
take something rather than nothing
because then if you have temperatures or
heights or something like that then you
remember to describe 200 all these
scores I want to make sure like I can
get from the bottom all the way up to
the top so if I'm going to start from 3
and then I'm going to go up and draw
some sort of equity or wall until I get
to 15 I guess I'll go even 3 because
conveniently 15 is a multiple 3 so I'm
going to go 3 and then ok so I've got
everything evenly spaced it's pretty
important that thing touches scale for
you because you're trying to make
arguments on the shape of this graph so
they need to be evenly spaced out if
you're saying that that's really three
is actually three and so on okay now
you'll find numbers all you need to do
is to know what the numbers are and
place them in the appropriate box or
here just a bit above though we're going
to hole with them so here's three I'm
going to draw a vertical line above
three this is my minimum four and a half
for your heart is exactly halfway
between three and six which is kind of
convenient okay so down here I'm going
to draw another vertical line for four
o'clock because four and a half is not
on not one of the points that are
labeled answer and I don't want you to
waste time going like three four five
percent due to all the digits it's just
going to come really full and you still
won't have four half up there anyway
good start so I am going to do wants the
dot down like this
and label that as a value so that I have
it precisely
picarello what is the next number
littledevil
seven you seem tired for all these
vertical lines nicely done parallel to
each other and horizontally seven again
was not appointment I had labeled before
side label yes now what my next one nine
nine nine men are going to take my yep
so nine is conveniently already marked
in and then the last one is 15 okay so
my five marking correspond to the
clients numbers in my fact number
summary so now I'm going to make the box
in those students the box is in the
middle the box represents the
interquartile range
so here's quartile range here so I'm
going to draw a line across the top and
what's the water and there's the box
that box plots are they got done okay
how much of the risk is is on another
the whiskers with the whiskers go so you
might have seen me before whatever
Thunder the detail but whiskers are the
outsides it's right so if they're I want
to distinguish this from the box so I'm
going to draw them in the middle what my
bad
okay you should have seen this elite
force or even if you didn't do a bit of
detail okay so this is a box and
whiskers okay this box and whisker plot
now described was just at a glance what
is this arm what is this does that what
does it look like how would you describe
it so on top of this I gave it like a
stream and put a few manners in here
these guys in the middle the box right
this is the middle 50%
half of the people the most average of
the people right
husbands are set me up between four and
a half and nine that's the little beauty
percent so I don't know it's 50 but I do
50 okay because these quartiles divide
up my score into remember four equal
sections that means that the same number
of people here and here and here and
here
does that make sense so I could also say
there's the middle 50% of er is the
lower 25 and lastly this is the upper 25
okay so for this box a whisker plot what
can we conclude well we can see where
the meeting is this is where the middle
score is proper watering Harper Bob what
do you look at this when you look at it
see having a really long whisker over
here what did that be so our lives are
people who are outside this building
range okay
we would usually go to the bottom people
usually our allies but normal ways for
example these scores are all between 350
suppose the tests out of 50 okay you
remember I gave you that we've said
before though just by five right given
that okay if someone got four and some
words on six I don't think you would
call out of their allies would you like
they're right next to everyone else does
that make sense so just because they're
the top and bottom doesn't make an
outline our people who do mathematics a
turkey Wilbur there's a formal
definition for that I were worried about
it at the moment what I gather from this
thing here it is top 25 percent he's
really spread out over these marks valid
sense just graduated
since four and a half jianchi imagine if
I put the lowest scores for what would
that mean
but this set of scores remember each of
the five numbers separate out is 25% 25%
25% 25% yes has to do is skewed that's
right so this here then see how they're
really close together that means 25% of
people are all squeezed into there in a
tiny little space that means if I were
to draw this it would look like this you
have a need for this function what it's
called but if you better tailored going
positive so this is positive skew so
another way of thinking of it is if you
have a box and whisker plot you don't
need to graph it in a number way in
another way have a look at which whisker
is longer no longer whisker is a table
so this I can see it straight away is
positively skewed okay